all right flashpoint
returns ebon tiss what's going on it oh
you know back after a whole bunch of
road trip driving and things like that
so I'm glad to be back but it's uh it
was good saw all the two worst things so
I'm kind of done with that for a minute
yeah I'm pretty solid on that front for
now listen man getting away is always
good sometimes just to clear the mind
and destress we missed you you know I
didn't I didn't have the heart to do it
solo housing yeah I could do it but it
just so much info this is just too much
tonight yeah why the hash tag strap in
for a long point get started early but
you know no I've been thrown under the
bus no honestly just wildlings if it
wasn't you always something going on and
you're like oh I'm totally gonna start
it early and then we are back in the mix
man we got a lot to talk about
very exciting let's get to it man what's
going on uh well for us at least we've
got a couple two obstacle
we've got Soulstice of here heroes is
live we've got a little Forsaken tidbit
drops here and there we've got this
wonderful new weapons gear to talk about
so quite a few things we're gonna try
and know in chronological order try not
to have way too long on everything and
then just gonna pick any random tangents
we always get off on so strap in guys
Longpoint coming we got a lot to cover
so first thing since I was in town well
step back a week do this we get Bungie
for the 26 so straight away first thing
is this right here so we've got the
Forsaken new weapons and gear trailer so
I want to just play this real quick and
then we're just gonna cut pause on each
one and talk about them as we go through
looking good
yeah and it's this one this hit box so
you got two rockets
it's a one solar one voice I got a
question yes you lock on with both you
think it's my move or what do you guys
cuz it like a really big aiming reticle
it did um I don't know what my gut is
telling me that it it's it's gonna if it
does track it's gonna be light tracking
almost like hockey rocket launchers okay
I'm not like aggressive in the days of a
truth in the Gjallarhorn you know I'm
saying because I mean that would mean I
love truth he was kind of the epic
tracking but even just some tracking in
PDE actually like kind of worked would
be really great absolutely yeah
definitely ain't on because I feel if
it's aggressive
this is like a win button and because
especially you can get two kills like if
you get a little tracking like partway
across the big map yeah there's no
welcome down absolutely so all I can
think of if it does have some form of
aggressive tracking maybe they balance
it by implementing like a reticle
lock-on right okay yeah get that then
you get you know you guarantee kind of
thing just to kind of you know balance
that thing about that that's impressed
that looks fun yeah and this is like
kinda what I'm saying even chat there
for us T is use a lurker before now
we're just having a full-blown
conversation so nice we had it I like
how these are starting to feel exotic
that word is actually holding true now
so this is more of what I've been asking
for for forever so so yeah that one
looks cool
next yeah that's just awesome that's
fine
alright by the way just loving the look
of these right here anteus Ward's slide
to reflect projectiles now I've seen
people do reviews over these and I've
got the same idea it's fun in theory but
this is one of those I'm like it's gonna
be to do be like oh boy bomb cuz
somebody's just gonna boy bomb you fast
you can't slide so you oh you gotta be
running for these it's I wish it was
something a little more just not sliding
sliding is gonna be enough like yeah
yeah this this that's a good point
you know how practical is it right in
might be nice but what I'm hoping for is
generally stuff like this in destiny
sometimes have a secondary passive perk
so one could hope because let's be
honest what the scenario is to try to
pull that off you know it's very rare
for you to give up your expects lab so
there needs to be something passive that
you know constantly does something to
aid you in addition to this feature you
know I mean that's what I'm thinking on
so we'll see what they did it that the
fantasy of it is it's dope I like that
yeah and this is kind of my general like
issue with a lot of what we got going on
in d2 and some of the weapons are really
starting to feel cool the armor still
doesn't quite have the that exotic feel
like yes way rocket launcher of
different types and sounds are cool
slider reflect a projectile maybe prep
may be usable for armor I'm like they
just don't like they don't feel like on
the same level the weapons first they
are nor so yeah let's see if some of
them get there but we got one again like
some are more practical so next we've
got it was like Siri also I don't know
how hard it's gonna be the aim yeah
that's true we got our Trinity ghoul
this is gonna be the bow this is the one
we already saw in the previews for any
of the footage from gambit precision
kills create an electrical storm fire it
out yes
now there's a whole bunch of low-level
guys there so I'm pretty sure this is
like set up really well yes it's
actually gonna be this powerful okay set
up this little situation in Tamizh they
have one health and then the storm kills
them all
I was wonderful Ike that's how they set
these things up I completed that
actually how it does it the sandbox see
they getting into get busy they start
coming up with these cinematic things
from angles and like you said scenarios
that make this dad crazy like that would
be a fun team to be on all right make a
crazy situation so this gun looks good
can I mess with the entire seven bucks
and every way possible yes alright we're
gonna have some fun like I feel like
that's how that conversation goes yeah
yeah that's cool six coyote also for one
looks cool yeah talk to me like now
that's the hunter mobility I want oh
yeah but what I but I what I wish is
this is actually like a perk on the new
ninja tree as opposed to an exotic hmm
I'd almost like to see the double dodged
be like you know you get that instead of
a smoke grenade like and that's your
mobility bill versus the smoke grenade
being like a smoke wall I'd like to
thank you
so I mean while the double dodge is cool
you give up your exotic for okay but
again are you gonna use six coyote over
warm husk or celestial or we're getting
flex like facts that's the part where
the armor there's there's always gonna
be an elite that's why we need I think
more you know bubbles and our builds so
yeah absolutely the IR that
customization mmm-hmm okay I got a posit
this thing looks too often so it is
detonate an explosion five hits three
four boom yeah yeah and that's a huge
explosion yeah we should have radius on
that yeah that's like bigger than a
curse they're all so that's legit right
there
then we're looking at this one do you
know it's coming if you've looked this
it says projectile sword so we're
getting back to a little bolt caster
actions yes I like the ornate look of it
because you actually have a hollow sword
with like a little jewel inside I mean
always art team killing it on these
things horse slash slash and fire dome
is awesome know that's interesting
thousand voices this has got to be one
of the craziest looking things take a
take like but this is again I'll get to
in a second you're gonna take this thing
you're gonna draw a line on the ground
and have it explode so it's gonna take
stuff like prometheus lens and hold
heart and outshine them in every way it
looks like well I mean in theory you're
not continuously
I know but it's late it's that theory
but like cranked up and this is why I
worry the new exotic new exotics and all
we can start fighting again literally
before we got started and the way they
ask the question is are there going to
be like you know updates for the old
subclass trees or or orbs or whatever
they call him he's like there will be
some bud bug fixes but nothing really to
planned at this time so it's I doesn't I
still don't think it sounds like they're
gonna do a lot we go back and listen to
it again because you're like dude I
listen to it I was like friendly did it
again this mornin like but yeah let you
know I was just gonna say forsaken is
lookin really good
like I'm like totally on hype train all
aboard choo-choo
I love how somebody on my text I forget
are my Twitter was like to to mother
truckers but my butt like forsaken looks
so good I'm kind of just like I'm
getting the feeling like stuff from like
the year one is gonna be fallin off
which part of me is actually okay with
now the subclasses is one thing because
you're stuck with those but of the new
weapons like outshine old weapons and we
actually all want to use new things
that's actually a really good thing
because I wish they would make bigger
transitions to like year two and kind of
like more of your old stuff so you're
not always using the same five guns
mm-hm subclasses though those I feel
need equated so you haven't have we'll
see now hey man listen we've been at
this and don't know let it fool you
y'all stay consistent you know what the
state of the game they have to keep
generating the interest especially
during this period because this is the
most typically dead period in destiny so
what they're doing is for
engagement I'm saying create an
excitement or skin gauge and people now
want to play now doing solstice you know
we're gonna get deeper into solstice you
know soon but um you know it's just one
of those things man they know the
position they're in and I think under
normal circumstances we would not get
all of this information now to your
point in reference to the exotics I mean
as far I mean as far as on the the old
stuff right that's that's really get the
bigger the thing like with all these
cool new stuff you know how much it will
the old stuff be effective you know
history has taught us with taking King
and things like that
those things always get kind of brought
up in like a silent patch right before
release now I now back to the specific
thing in question which was the Game
Informer um was the Game Informer
article Q&A like the last video they did
and it's like thirty if you guys want to
know the timestamp about 13 minutes 30
seconds go watch it while you guys are
like listen to us real quick
well you gotta let us know our thoughts
hit us up on Twitter let us know are you
on you know
Camp Cognito maybe like they're just
being subtle they're not telling us
everything are you in bond to this where
I'm like hey I think the subclasses
might get tiny bug fixes but like they I
don't think they're gonna get buff to
join like the level right right and
there's a good argument I get it you
know the argument for you could be like
you know hey they don't really have
enough time because they've been
crunching to get forsaken and maybe
those get up at a later date but the key
thing is in questions was a Game
Informer Scott Taylor and I forgot the
other gentleman's name he's really funny
but oh yeah is it like Steve cotton I
think is that yeah I think so I think so
and this question was asked about you
know the subclasses and their exact
answer was you know they do pause for a
second no it's like we don't have
anything to say at this time so I know
you interpreted it like yo it's not
coming and I can I can I could see you
some your argument I'm not totally
thinking you crazy now it is just
marketing 101 because when they ask
other questions when is this gonna be in
forsaken the answer
was no it felt like the question before
it had a similar tone of answer like
because they didn't want to say like I
feel like that was almost managing
expectations is what that one was they
were like uh it's like okay they don't
want to be like how we're gonna Buffum I
was like yeah we probably have some bug
fixes it's that like some of the stuff
they're like we're not saying right now
like there's that tone and then there's
like not in Forsaken and then that one
was like floating in a weird spot in
between like bug fixes yes big buffs
like I don't know so again again that's
my hunch versus your hunt my last point
and we'll say we'll leave with that
after Fantas if it was it coming they
have to say no like like they just to me
just comes down to deliverables you know
I'm saying like when is it gonna be
ready so they don't want to say oh you
know it definitely gonna be there at
loan and maybe it does come a week or
two after or whatever whatever but in my
heart I say it's coming but we'll leave
that for the day long point continue for
the fans and actually see what happens
so thousand voices this thing is bananas
yes you draw lines on the ground now
whatever shape you draw and make a video
of they could be kind of crude but we'll
have to find out you know that's gonna
happen so yeah did you see um daddles
with swats do this it is low okay like
you know what people gonna be drawing
autograph drawings use this thing to
blow up and be silly I thought it was
hilarious
oh yeah that's definitely gonna happen
yeah look at this thing it's just mm-hmm
you shout the frosty frosty said it
low-key everybody like it's a flyby
driving I'm like flip oh yeah
exploding Bheema fire that pretty much
just says it so insane ah now this one
could be crazy element explosion from
precision kinetic kills that's it well
can any kinetic weapon engines apart
like what does it work like yeah yeah
and then way
gender mmm interesting looks BAM
like that could be a problem
that could be a huge problem and that
thing I said both a plate I might agree
they felt good and really did you know
and and and not only that you're talking
now competitive trials and and glory you
know I'm saying using that kind of stuff
oh yeah oh so that's most of them I
think
oh no not quite not quite the legend
returns now that's it gives extra damage
after a kill but it also looked like it
exploded yeah dude it wasn't like I was
like a wave I asked perk yeah cuz it's
like fire like that was a little bigger
than normal
that's how for second I so yeah I mean
hopefully we give a little shout out to
Kade love there so we'll see yeah that's
gonna be interesting play with it is it
a maje weapon so dad that's cool hold on
pause the video frame by frame one of
the guys in jet leprechaun is like I'm
becoming a bow main that these are the
times when I see like I love the look of
stuff like this somewhat like the the
Crimson ornament that's like ornate and
stuff like the time it takes to render
that stuff so they do a fantastic job
these design like they're so unique and
it just makes you want to learn more
about that gun like where did it come
like that's a lortab gun right so
absolutely what greatest thing was this
looks crazy like that looks like half
mercury half warmind across into
egyptian all of it looks like it's not
like an ivory it literally looks like an
ivory shotgun handle to him like I love
like all the Egyptian Osiris II kind of
you know that's almost hieroglyphic
stuff on it like it this thing's is
looks cool I can't
don't know what it does yeah so they get
a couple secrets but again kind of back
to what we're saying it's like I know
they're going for the marketing but man
and I don't know I'm hoping there's no
I've skipped the dreaming city dreaming
city info just because like that's I
don't want it to be spoiled but man I
don't know if I'm gonna be surprised by
more than like two or three exotics I
feel like we've seen most by now yeah I
will be exciting with it launched that's
what I'm ready wait a minute what's up
what's up we'll look at that hand cannon
that doesn't look the same because that
almost has a knife on the bottom that's
not in spades is it dad does not look
like ASA spades at all well I don't know
man
like I'm just gonna tell you right now I
need one exotic or this whole DLC is a
fail probably only person he won get
over it nope yeah like oh your three tap
shotgun oh it was like a pole shot e and
I use that I went to the lighthouse
stuff first-ever the only job because of
that gun like that gun and then it had
recovery buff yeah little bit of that
radius I'm saying you know I mean and
you would hope it comes back because of
you know where we are with you know the
prison and all that stuff with thorne
version of that or something yeah man I
love that think it had crazy Rangers a
little weird to handle but you know come
on boy that was good and I love the
design maybe had a little fire coming
out though being the front you don't
remember it it was basically kind of
like I don't know torch the whole time
so we'll see hopefully we get it what
not at the DLC will still be fantastic
about this me baby self good team all
right
yeah continue up and pinch at thorn
please and be like that hold that
thought
and then that one we know about that
we're getting that tiger face this one
is different this looks like kind of a
auto-rifle looking situation but like
some barrel is very smooth so it's
definitely its own look there which is a
little cooler looks cool this is what I
need to know about what is this what is
this what what classes yes shoulders
don't look big enough to be a Titan but
I always feel like I kept seeing it on
Titans every thought it was I don't know
mesh face and all that crazy stuff he's
got like a skull cap on - it's weird
this is crazy
I have to know what that's about why are
the wait why is the jet helmet back why
is this thing back we've got a place
about just like I'm tired of the big
airplane wings you guys came out I just
thought it was it was over the top but I
just loved it like Titan stuff is over
the top but I want like I don't know
give me a little tweak to it don't give
me the same helm for the third I've seen
this oh you got a shout out fallout
please yeah what are the funniest tweets
he's breaking this thing down like I
went breaking it down yeah he gets
through that part I said you need to
tell me after the like this thing still
survives he's like this helm literally
has an f-22 on your forehead yeah it's
just like it's a jet on your head so
guys exotic I mean again if you don't
have enough reason to come back for
forsaken by the way if you have for some
reason miss destiny to entirely $60 gets
you all of your 1 and 4
bacon that's insane that's so much stuff
to play I see much Kurt's tiresome
warmind aren't great play it all
together for 60 bucks and then go enjoy
forsaken you can be like Oh everything
just gets better as they go so hashtag
sorry they do kill Cade pretty quick if
you're starting fresh but you know
you'll get to it so yes well that was
probably a fairly long coverage on that
but we had to touch on it cuz we man we
had oh it's so heavy get opinions out
there so heads up your to reveal stream
is on Tuesday so we can have some stuff
to talk about next week as well we're
gonna be here you're gonna want to be
here but also you're gonna want to be
there Tuesday August 7th 10 a.m. Pacific
1 a.m. 1 p.m. Eastern
join the stream we get to a little
preview video but basically they're
showing like faster time to kill 3 tab
hand cannons you've got the IQ low
shotgun going into your energy slot it
looks like things are changing and
moving on that coming out of the dark
shadow of the chat he's like if that
helmet is the spirit the helm of Spirit
Airlines you hit the worst airline by
the way the crucible abs did come
through again I missed it unfortunately
so I don't know you get a chance to play
this at all but lockdown actually I was
so disinterested I think I blame you you
know remember cuz we thought it was
gonna be so much more so it's not
nothing I'm gonna be way too much I got
grants to do man I got you know too much
grounds last week would have been ok to
work on some stuff but yeah grinding
this week
you got whisper the worm coming back
this weekend so that'll be back but yeah
it's like zone control with a twist
basically just on percentages so I mean
in theory it kind of sounds okay to
bring that zone back where it's very
very I do like that it is objective we
do get one of those so another objective
mode is cool but again it's just like
okay at zone control again it's still
fairly tame one time I want them to be
like hey we're gonna break crucible this
weekend there's gonna be like 12 capture
points 200 kill just met like have a
little fun once I just want to see them
do that one time
just to get a little out there that's
great so take crucible abs a little
farther you'll be happy with us so now
we got to talk about this no question
about it let's get to it so heads up by
the way even if you haven't bought
forsaken you're gonna get to test out
some things a week before it's very cool
very cool weapons lot changes are coming
on August 28th so Wednesday heroes ins
we get to test them out now for
clarification on August 28th if you guys
were fallen on Twitter DM G said hey
nothing's gonna be available so
whatever's on your character make sure
it's clear not totally true you won't be
able to have access to your collections
you will still be able to have access to
your vaults so yeah grab them yeah
you'll be able to clear like test out a
lot more things I was like if you can
only have what's on your character
that's gonna be kind of tough so mostly
a whole lot of stuff move around and you
get a filthy revealed before everything
starts and both shader dilution you can
clean up your inventory the vaults gonna
be there I love how it gives us a week
to like prep everything so I don't log
in on forsaken and have to do inventory
yeah yeah I have all that done I log in
and play again defending my point look
at what they're doing look look at the
roadmap look at every week we have
something to do to look forward to and
that is the ultimate you know caveat
like a really good gesture to keep again
they're breaking protocol and I don't
mind it in this case because the game
needs it and this is cool I would have
never thought we would have gotten
weapon slot changes before the release
of forsaken and that also helps the base
that's on the on the on the fence right
that's like cuz remember that that's
like really key like remember we had dr.
amnesia on you know these were the
things he's like I am NOT coming back to
destiny until random roles and weapon
slots BAM there we go
playing that so we got weapons slot
changes so I mean as they showed in the
little preview they have a whisper the
warm on their back
mm-hm and then also they're holding that
kilos so in essence I can loose out of
power which is already a hell of a
shotgun by the way I still need to get
that thing so I'm gonna be grinding
mismo
protocol at some point soon I still have
to do that for triumph but those two
alone that's a hell of a combination if
you throw like a pulse rifle in there
for like mid-range action shotgun and
sniper like that gets back to the field
of like okay I'm up close pull up my
shotgun BAM yeah had a dude halfway
across the map sniping me straight
sideways pick them up with where the
worm okay back to it you know to happen
that's the feel of the gun play that we
miss and it's destiny to year one
experiment dusty one year one also an
experiment you can say beta you cannot
but honestly it's a live game and they
you know they have to learn they stepped
out of their box now they're putting
things in box I just like that they're
actually evolving like if they and this
is the point where I do want to because
some people like I just wish they would
have done destiny one year for whatever
I'm like and we wouldn't have well
growing pains suck we wouldn't have the
evolution to these weapons slot changes
where it's all over the place now it
would have just been the same mm-hmm no
you're right it's it's to me it's the
perfect storm because it's the evolution
of what we want right we wanted this but
d1 didn't have you know this level of
customization that they intend on it
implementing so yeah this this is this
is cool you know say I like that they
didn't just bring back verbatim exactly
how the one was they're adding a little
spice to it this is gonna be interesting
you know shout out to the chat you know
I'm just saying as far as ammo
consumption you know for the people
worrying about Opie bills you know you
got to keep that in mind if you have a
bunch of things all using you know
special ammo and running you know
whatever there's three to three shotgun
thing you know said like is you no one's
gonna use power no doubt but you have to
keep in mind of that thing and that's
gonna create different dynamics that are
real quick to leprechaun in chat sorry
about the house fire glad everybody's
okay
but yeah I mean as you say and just rip
my stream setup it's one of those and
this will be one that I've heard people
say it before as well sorry to go off on
a tangent but no no no no no so salute
to Lepke hopefully gets things back in
place at that yeah it's just like they
are material things I'm very happy
you're safe thank you for that yes and
again for everybody
they're taking it and be thankful for
everything you've got remember these are
just video games we're gonna chat we're
gonna be opinionated we might get a
little heated with stuff but they are
games life's outside of it enjoy a
little second just had to say that for a
second um back to it though so weapons
lots gonna be cool
gonna get to touch on those milestones
and challenges updates so I don't know
if the milestone refresh where it's like
every four days is gonna be coming the
raids on the weekly milestones more
frequently you're gonna have some daily
stuff like lots of things are gonna be
coming director updates you're gonna see
the locations on the map so they're
literally prepping everything so then
four seconds just like go heroic story
missions this one I want to see yeah now
if they feel the way solstice of Heroes
does hell yeah
mmm-hmm that's the level of a heroic
story mission yeah absolutely absolutely
and Loki I mean even though Thoreau said
I don't want to replayed at story
because it sucks in the way dancing to
is now once you do the campaign yeah you
don't say exactly right so it's just
like you know and I'm such an Osiris
fanboy that even though that you know
DLC was terrible for the most part you
know I did like just going through start
trying whatever information you get
would love to kind of replay it and you
know it's the only town but probably got
a chance to get see them if they were
they bring these things back because I'm
not playing see
but I'm very very interested in what's
underneath is what I'm second most
looking forward to
both of these honestly both shader
deletion clean out that vault clean out
stuff here in the crap you don't want to
look at row you know how many Atlantic
wash shaders and it be those worse one
you know which ones I can't stay into a
tangent Oh what you can I don't like
different K shaders man dum-dum ATZ
shaders the tree box stuff big dark and
dead zone paint that jungle forest shade
is out of here like they don't delete
nose
I got like 60 to 90 each oh my god it's
killing me because sometimes you get the
cool shaders you only get limited but
then it's going to the post you know
master and stuff like that just give me
that mass to Lee done yeah involves face
this is just gonna be nice to be like
all right clean up some chairs move
vaults around you know mobs are gonna
get all switched in so but the 200 volt
like logging of course they could not
have to work you can you know do a
little mod space managing if you want
but like you can just jump in and go and
that's gonna be great so yeah now year
twos I get a few updates gear
collections we know which is just all
the collections of your your one stuff
the exotics are updating all those are
gonna be their in-game triumphs life
we've got and also the new triumphs and
lortabs and all that stuff coming weapon
raising randomization mod systems which
are starting to sound a little better
they did a little bit on that QA yeah so
they were saying for the armor they're
gonna have mods for like one for ammo
economy for like scout rifles and the
other one I forget the other one no I
won well when I got my ear was when he
talked about in air accuracy one yes and
I was like oh now I can actually attempt
to use my warlock build top tree a two
minute of sky you know because once
you're up there these cool perks happen
but the in our accuracy is so trashed
that you know yeah so now you give me
that I'm excited yeah three new crucible
maps one extra PlayStation is fine I
mean yeah whatever no it's more like
honestly like the rotation of the maps
there's there's enough in there that I
feel like not too bad three more is just
more rotation and it's not just a PvP
game or like here's more maps for a PvP
writing a boatload of other stuff and a
few more maps like new crucible mode
which what is that called again imma
look at stuff for too long oh man was it
it's like the what's the name of it I'm
forgetting to it yeah we're really good
destiny podcasters guys oh yeah we're
awesome we're asleep right here but yeah
a new crucible mode go ahead and I look
that up if you want a power-mad with an
iron vanillin promo trial in game or
new bounties which hopefully will be
more maybe some exotics which they've
said there will be some exotic
boundaries which woo
and more so I mean so much stuff is
coming little demo break through break
through break that's right that's gonna
like a not a progressive thing because
what I picture breakthrough to be do
they like zone control almost like what
I would like to see is something like oh
I remember so like if you capture in the
middle point then you have to go like
capture the like that you go on they go
on the defensive if you lose or you're
on the offensive like from the middle
it's responding closer so it's that
whole thing so I remember now so it
sounds kind of cool definitely more
objective it's got its rounds but like
if you plank go shoot for the middle but
then you can defend then maybe you'll do
alright or vice versa
so has an interesting twist to it on
some of those though I wish occasionally
like I know some modes are built for
competitive but what if it was just like
random quick play with like the crazy
matchmaking they've got going on and
just let us practice a little countdown
a little like other stuff in just quick
play I'd love to see those yeah just be
a debater to be selectable again you
know hi great yep so I got new
challenges all the critical all that
stuff is coming so a couple dates
you guys know Soulstice if heroes began
the combat reveal stream is on the 7th
on Tuesday mayhem also starts on Tuesday
after that we've got at last iron banner
they've got Gamescom which might
probably have a final trailer doubles
I'm like me solstice of Heroes will end
the day before the patch comes out and
then prep for forsaken so calendar their
heads up by the way if you're struggling
with your super kills and your green
armor for solstice mayhem is next week
if you're gonna do it at all for your
characters do it then no doubt by the
way shout out to this thing I already
pre-ordered it let you do grim or
anthology whoa it looks crispy man like
anything looks like the big like leather
kind of like textured
like it's really clean yeah so it's a
way to have it all together they're
gonna have probably everything from d1
I'd imagined so that's kind of Awesome
I'm pretty sure when vibe saw this he's
late he's like and this will be the
audio book of the grimoire done by by
first shout out the myelin games man
because this is one of the reasons why
yeah and did you see his tweet a
reference to uh you talking to a random
person who was a destiny fan and the guy
like instead of like he didn't realize
what myelin was and he's just like yeah
you know that's so cool like they almost
reached out to bite to get this dirt and
they're like he's like faceball
but he joked on himself like he shot out
the bike they both kind of took it well
cuz obviously we know the history you
know by should have been there you know
I mean it's not did that to do this walk
but he just should have been invited to
the summit in jail both of them you know
I'm saying
so Island got it there but there's kind
of funny story he was like
self-deprecating you know how he did it
and shut the mana let me he's a good
dude really humble and I'm still glad
you know obviously won't both both of
them on it but at least they got the law
community at least represented by a
person yeah so I mean it looks really
cool even just a picture ID here with
auric so there's just gonna be a decent
graphics and art in there
I love how like ever every picture looks
like it's gotten you know destiny
texturing just yeah it's well done I
think it was 40 but like I don't even
know if it was 40 bucks it wasn't that
bad it's like totally worth it remain so
your destiny fan heads-up but other nets
new monarchy did pull it out not very
shocking we got some more on the next
table we'll get to that in a little bit
but yeah dead orbit like see this is
kind of the way I feel it went if you
got dead orbit you grinded it out then
we moved on and like the players who
were grinding it every every time and
going for the level of 50 who were like
the hardcore and they were the ones who
basically Titan decided the faction
drinks because the players who pledged
dead orbit won every time yes but the
actual faction packages were basically
by catalyst so dead orbit future and
then finally here so our
or players still pulling it out and this
is again another reason don't neglect
your hard core
yeah they're making this happen for all
your population so but yeah not too much
else guys this is again everything
coming with forsaken so new story
tangled shore dreaming city levels up to
600 you got gambit new raid which I
can't wait
new exotics triumphs all that stuff's in
there but you got to get the expansion
seasons that's for everybody remember
seasonal rewards quality alive crucible
Maps the and the crucial Maps for
everybody is like that's that's awesome
so and then the annual pass we'll just
have to see black armory Joker's wild
penumbra no idea yeah interesting name
very curious to see where they go with
those yeah seriously like penumbra has
like a literally like astrological thing
to it the other two could be anything
who knows yeah so number two this week
it runs you for this week finally
actually catching up chronologically to
this week if you guys haven't played the
spark mission go do it
it's hilarious but it's like oh just
once everybody find oh there's four oh
my god a little bit insane in kind of a
fun way there's a fun way you cruise and
it really doing cool stuff with the reed
axes yeah that's the type of stuff like
I know it takes a whole year for us to
get to us unfortunately so I wish I
didn't take as long but that's like
that's all I want like some missions to
like go back and be like that's what I
want to challenge mission to be like
that type of stuff is cool so you don't
need to see the story you don't need to
see the cutscenes but have the the meat
of the mission and have some cool spin
on it that was new absolutely some of
the art this week by the way like this
these are really cool for solstice of
Heroes this is hilarious the like little
nesting cup of servitors just nice art
out there in the community so first
thing they started with this week is
community highlights you know the
numbers in this are kind of insane since
it's just from warmind on and I almost
have a hard time believing this ya know
like these are insane so if you guys
have been played your part of this we're
gonna start here with defection stuff so
the number of characters who pledged
this is a also guys if you're wondering
how many people are playing
yes pledged to future war cult hunters
pledging to dead women dead or but
obviously one you guys can see because
that was just general of everybody
wanted on the catalyst the most and then
hunters pledged to do monarchy I know we
don't have like photos like even if you
have one of each there's still hundreds
of thousands of players playing these
things so and this is at a low spotted
nesting right now exact at sticky hats
this is a low spot forsaken you may a
little double easy I think so mmm-hmm
with the hype that's going on it's a big
year two expansion I'm thinking it's
gonna be a good time for people to come
back so those are cool numbers to see
the engrams open dead orbit absolutely
crushed it but I'm pretty sure that was
the first week where the most of that
was in when it comes to raids this is
the one that blows my mind since war
mine there have been six million four
hundred thousand normal raid clears
that's it
what that's a lot that's a lot that dad
surprised me too
that definitely surprised me absolutely
there's some that do it over and over
and over so I mean some of this is
skewed but still even 750 thousand
prestige regular clears that hasn't been
that long so no you're right and shut
shout out to my team and I'm also monkey
punch what's going on to look at County
about to do we're doing goods could be
back um yeah like Shelton like my clan I
love pockets coming do we run those
things man like you know I got guys that
run it like magic and it just ring my
machine and over and over so it could
that could be a factor that the base
that has remained has they dedicate but
that's still a high high number you know
so it's good to see do it like you said
during the quote-unquote low at low
point yeah and then you've got the
amount of kills versus deaths in there
1.6 billion kills in Leviathan that's
just crazy crazy numbers but these are
sometimes cool to see but honestly it's
just a big shout out for everything
going on in
the game I'm not really surprised as 263
million public events cuz that's all we
ever do you will get the Solstice
appears in a little bit but I'm actually
glad for the variety escalation protocol
waves that's higher than I expected
because I could never get past two right
there I finally get it done
oh nice no I'm sorry ain't get that
aren't she's kind of brutal man at least
we'll be ID I didn't get anything me
addict in a couple of minute okay yeah
we did the whole night we do I'm gonna
tell you right now just real quick
people out and talking to them and stuff
like we didn't even do that we just had
like literally on Xbox we had about 12
people in chat you know each one would
go to specific specific the same area
and like load in and then once it only
takes that if you have that many people
it doesn't take that long for one to see
the other and then we would send that
once we send groups of two to each
person's you know party that saw each
other yeah I'm gonna say this for my
first time like really playing it
coordinator squad like it almost feels
that it needs to be a must in Patrol
space from that I haven't had that much
fun in a long time with this it is when
you've got a group that's why they need
matchmaking it is so much at one bro
orange is low little wonky I didn't get
I got like some armors and boots but I
think the only weapon you know I'm
saying cuz I really was you know but
still
ton of fun Melton bosses the sequences
stuff like that to me that should be a
mandatory style mold in a patrol or have
its own separate thing like a bit yeah I
mean either a separate thing like game
but as you're saying or meant some thing
because that's what everyone says the
same thing is EXO you did like it's hard
for some of us to get there but when you
finally get to do it like coordination
people working together working on the
bus okay you gotta go and like one of
them's like a big like night where you
got to pop your bubbles and use the
swords on him to drop his shield like
reversed Curtis tile like that's like a
mini little raid in patrol a it's kind
of amazing but like have so many people
somehow there's 77 million waves but
it's probably like 70 million level ones
and then these are the rest of people
who finish their like 7 million but no
it's a really really really cool thing
and I haven't even got to do it yet so
I'm looking forward to it as well I only
hear awesome stuff when people actually
get to finish it yes and then here's the
real ones so a hashtag boilers whisper
the worms out there that's a pretty
small number but when you want to talk
small render explain more and I'm
honestly okay with it I love it that's
tiny I love it I love it too but I'm
low-key speaking about Claire like dude
I want this like I love seeing stuff
like that with the rarity that's all I
need cuz just in case the meta changes
and let's just say high impact pulses
get a buff now you throw that desperado
yeah it's gonna be crazy but in the next
month like if I finish up or I'm kind of
done with the whole grind now the glory
matchmaking is at least how it should be
by point like if you're at zero you
start at zero and that's how you're
matching with you at least if it's set
up that way to get to fabled probably
still gonna be tough you're gonna have
to find like some people to play with
but it's at least sound something I
could try if I you know have some time
so that's actually these are kind of
cool stats like whisper the worm I love
the secret quest for one it still looks
awesome that still looks like a dragon
on the end but whispers a beast by the
way it's an Isis video of them taking on
eater the world's one face him without
even trying
Wow one phase 1 phase our ghost without
just like hardly betting and I was just
like I checked out wow dude done like so
crazy fast was also prison
so the waited till it was solar that's
what this week is even better it's got
snipers and prism solar sniper gun Don
finished all got it do it oh I got to do
this yeah like I've got some time
tomorrow shout out if you guys are
looking for anybody on PC I'm like gonna
be around most of the weekend cuz my
wife's got some stuff he's doing so
probably be playing a lot mm-hmm
yeah absolutely oh here's a little nice
little tidbit to finish it up
800 million and that's just this is like
a joke at themself by the way bulk
shader deletion crap people don't want
to gear it up so that's why you know
it's coming because they they even
clownin themselves
absolutely Larry's so heads up as u2
comes to a close many of you were
searching for every available item a
piece of gear so there are destiny gear
sets which is kind of a thing they
talked about if you guys go there you
can see what you're missing what you
don't have what you do stuff like that
but as when forsaken launches some
things are going to like fade away
because whatever is in year one the
roles are gonna go away now some things
might get a buff and come back in a
different way but some things are just
not coming back so if you don't have
them like the ones I worry about was
like I need to like drop all my little
weaponsmith parts I can get more I need
one more man
I need a saloon okay I have a void in an
arc but I need a third one first is I
don't think you're gonna be able to
switch like yeah that's a good question
yeah I don't know very good question I
don't know if you're gonna be able to
switch like energy type anymore so if
you don't have like you know mm there's
specific one in the flow you got yeah I
tend to go for it so I can rock with my
Nazareth in the energy spot okay but um
yeah I mean there's certain things you
kind of need you know weapon diversity
and it's gonna be interesting to see if
those since the old MA system you know
here is gonna be completely change um
how they're gonna handle that aspect
with the elements do we still have the
ability to change elements so will be
interesting so Vanguard year one weapons
and armor seasonal rewards crucible same
thing gunsmith basically the same thing
and some emblems there I Cora trials of
the 9 iron banner most year one stuff
probably not coming back so yeah use
this time and you're grinding see if
there's anything you don't have I mean
if you do have one place where you're
missing some stuff you got some weapon
parts you're holding on to and you don't
have a Manan yet dump some see if you
can get one because you're gonna get
plenty more but while is your one
weapons will be retired from fenders
their stalks will be refreshed with new
venture features new gear featuring
random roles which will be good because
hopefully we get back to checking out
the vendor gear see if there's anything
good like I was kind of love checking
those every week some items may return
in year two but not exactly as you
remember right you are looking at ten
different better Devils come September
for a small number of weapons that you
know and
we'll be updated a year two standards
featuring random roles and a capacity to
accept year two weapon mods so it sounds
like your one weapon mods may not I
don't know on the energy type no video
say something but I don't know like
roost rotor but yeah it's gonna be
interesting eyes we haven't got I don't
know anything definitive on it but
anyway man I'm just excited for the
prospect of uh I mean it's good that
some of you on stuff you know will come
back and stuff but I'm just so excited
about the prospects of the year to stuff
and it's gonna be a genuine exciting
it's to to experiment that kind of stuff
it's gonna be like here's the question
though I hope they have some mods I hope
they have perks in year two that can
keep up cuz you can't have this like
nameless midnight better than and not
have any random world that's gonna be
sex facts gotta make sure and have like
stuff that's gonna be better or
everyone's just gonna upgrade better
Devils in the name in diamond and it's
not gonna matter so yeah we'll see they
did a tiny little stream here so I'll
play it real quick for you guys mm-hmm
right here yeah how many shots this
handgun takes and this is gonna tell you
when they're gonna talk about time to
kill mm-hmm
one two three done mm three tap better
double a hand can is badass that was
like my first favorite archetype man and
it just it pains me how they are right
now you know the four tap is just brutal
on a hand cannon and hey TT k man let's
go you know when I heard my new ski jump
out and say that and I said okay did to
me this is sandbox this is this is
sandbox I don't know if everything is
gonna get TT Kade up but I my gut tells
me like I was saying you with the
subclasses know everything that's weak
that they they have the data now it's
you know your two they have the data
they that's one thing about Bungie
that's the way they operate shout out
the document again they like to operate
off data and a law
a longer period of it and now that they
have it hand cannons high impact Scouts
high impact pulses those are hurting you
know I mean and grenade launchers as
always but oh my god those are even of
things they'll I know it's like dude if
you don't got played it's just like why
even bother but um yeah it's gonna be I
think that's what we're gonna see I
think that that's why I'm going crazy
for reg it's my clan is like oh no one
cares about that work and I got a funny
I know how Bungie operates my gut
instinct tells me that archetype as a
whole is going to get buffs so you're
gonna be able to dust off old weapons
and really see some new TT cases some
new effectiveness and there's gonna be
new meta I'm telling you that's why I
saw this kind of stuff I'm like yep I
see you sandbox T I know it's coming but
this is the other thing so this is where
they're talking about I kill doses being
held and he's guts worse for the worm on
his back so the weapon slot changes are
gonna be particularly interesting so
looking forward to seeing what all move
you're gonna just have to like log in
and look in your inventory and be like
alright where's everything at like I'm
looking for a moment and it's a kinetic
looking for it just like stuff's gonna
move all around so and then be a thing
like so if energy slots don't matter
then maybe if the minion turns into a
scout then it's our kinetic it's not
gonna so I don't know what's gonna move
around so Woolsey mm-hmm hard to tell
alright so hold on I can see what tabs I
got up here okay let's go before you get
too far down mmm most of heroes yeah
let's talk what you want to talk about
just generally which just what do you
think about it how soul are like how do
you think they it would be event like
you've probably seen most of it so far
um initially very cool to go back to the
tower in a different space that really
was a cool little thing I like the voice
thing without the car
you know I like the whole story behind
it's kind of cool remember what you did
you know any old stuffs I like that I
like the idea of weather gear that you
know you're kind of physically renewing
yourself from what happened that's cool
um it I wouldn't say like this is a game
changing mode like that but I will say
this is the stuff like I said from a
grind perspective that a lot of people
gonna be invested in and I started it
you gotta mean some of the grinds little
wonky you know certain things but
there's a lot of the grind that's pretty
easy if you watch ebon tas's videos but
um you know yeah you can do some solo
farming and stuff like that now this is
not going to interest everything but I
think this is more of an ode to the
hardcore right and especially with the
moments of the triumphs and to me this
is just more testament that they know
their base right because at the end of
the day 400 gear and all that stuff is
it really important with force I can
come in no no it's it's a show-off piece
right it I've done this I dedicated
myself to this game and now I'm being
rewarded in some form right and that's
what the hawk or what that's that's
literally what the one you gotta respect
the time investment and I think that's
what this really is and as a summer yeah
I like it I like I thought it was a
strong attempt is it perfect no but a
very strong attempt out to buy and I
definitely I'll be playing it and you
got so much for some versatility of
modes and things that they want you to
do per gear say so that's me you know I
give it I give it a good strong rating
so what was your I guess I give my
opinions on it too please yeah I mean
just in general like going to the tower
heaven I Quora talk get her at least
involved when something is nice because
she's not the word like you don't man
she definitely sticks to herself yes new
monarchy side of that tower I'm over
here not in them but now seriously like
it was kind of cool
the missions have been the missions were
fun first time through I mean if you
replay them
you're only gonna do three like if you
do it on you know your characters to do
it three times if you do it on all three
you'll do it nine but I mean it's play
them through and you're gonna it gives
you a reason to do some different things
yeah and this is where I think faction
rallies need to learn from this yeah is
a variety of activities we can and
basically it almost makes you do yeah
it's gonna now the things that kind of
annoy some people are crucible yeah now
ten kills in crucible that's not that
bad for the green but it's the thirty
super kills invertible now I have some
games where I got like I had one game I
got six I was like I got four and then I
got two and I was using hammers and it's
like the biggest thing I can say is if
you guys are listening or watching Nick
you're super don't go Nova Bob you're
gonna use it on one and it's gonna take
you thirty games go you know go Don
Blade try and get at least two out of
each one yeah and then some people are
as well I popped my hammers then
everybody else pops their hammers at the
same time at top of the screen see who
has them available if you only at least
get the most out of one super let
everybody's gonna start getting them and
start popping them back and forth it's
like when I get heavy ammo I'm gonna get
my heavy ammo alright used to at least
in d1 and hide for a second because the
heavy ammo would spawn at the same time
for everybody I'd let all the crazy
people nuke it out hangout and then once
all of those people are dead I walk out
with my machine gun and have like five
kills just guys we can compare so same
thing save your super for a little
longer even if you only get one per
match so you're not like doing it at the
same time six other supers are going on
so I mean it's random matchmaking it's
gonna be a little rough and honestly
just wait for next week mayhem is coming
biggest things yep that's what just
about to say if you frustrated with it
do everything else just wait for mana
you can knock it out you know
same-same you and now if you guys need
to issue helps with the orbs I get a
video the nightfall this week use the
opening section just grind that thing
out cuz more orbs drop from the orange
bar enemies and yellow so there's just
you know heavy goblins in there all over
the place meld those with your heavy
ammo over and over and over I had just
like a smattering of all colors on the
ground it was
[Laughter]
but yeah so I think it's kind of cool
they like they make you go through the
store by the way what's your favorite
redux mission um to be honest I haven't
done a lot but the servitors update that
was cool pretty much that one right now
I'm not mad I'm not too far in because I
was working on um you know the crucible
stuff and I basically what I wanted to
do it I want to do all the grindy and
annoying stuff during the week so the
weekend is just really about me doing
the redux is and finishing off the last
parts of these checklist I'm saying so I
I knew the stuff I didn't want to do
asked you know what crucible let me
stick my behind in here and just get
this thing done you know I mean I spent
you know two days got it done ran nova
just waited I always used it on like
when control when they would all clamp
up you know saying and then I just wrote
a Slover and that's how at least my big
my whole goal yeah gotta call it this
Lola baby like my whole thing is at
minimum I want to get two kills with
that super like that's what I was going
for so little there was times I was
breaking rules and not really pretty
trying to control you know do the play
winning strategies just selfishly to get
my super cool yeah so I mean you go
slope over dawn blade for more kills or
you just like you know it's more of a
guarantee it's more of a guaranteed a
problem with dawn blade unfortunately in
PvP is yes it tracks it doesn't have the
distance you think it has and it's not
as accurate as you think it as from
distance whereas the cool thing about
Slover even if they like basically if
they all clamped up or not even that
let's just say there across the map team
shouting groups of three or four you
could send that boy and they're gonna
scatter but it's still gonna hunt down
one of them in if to anyone is in
proximity when it splits into four
you're gonna get a multi point so I feel
definitely it was more effective you
know that's where I'm at I don't know
yeah I mean tight nothing cameras is
probably an easy one
yeah
or hunter you could I've seen a lot of
Ark Striders but else's Golden Gun could
be good too yes fun have the map set up
like if it's close quarters like you
know go Art Fair all day long but if you
got some range shots like Golden Gun it
but yeah for like I hadn't played it yet
so it's kind of curious so I'll let the
tribe both yeah at Rice Louisville man
I'm telling you Slover will get you
there you'll get any time you get a
super you're guarantee or two and just
either use exotics or things that if you
can to build up um what's your car to
build up you want your super all the
time so whatever you anything that you
have or actually stormcaller
with crown of Tempest that's a good one
too there you know because it just keeps
it going you know and so these are
things you just want to do yeah so yeah
some pretty cool stuff the armor
upgrades are cool like you get the
Scorch and you're like alright so we
bleached it and then we're gonna end up
with the fancy stuff now I got like two
of the glows from a couple packages yeah
I liken them and I also like how they
pair up with your subclasses even more I
like the subtlety of that because if
it's like if it's purple in your like
it's subtle but if you're going solar
BAM there it is like it's ready very
cool very cool definitely like that nice
touch and to me a low-key sneaky way of
inbreeding Kromah back if you think
about it oh no it's exactly what that is
is good my curiosities of cromoz gonna
be in Forsaken - yeah good question I've
always liked it you know just adds
another layer of customization you know
and I'm playing rainbow or you can do
some people did turn a chrome off you
guys like okay so my throw up turn it
off we done but yeah so you're gonna
it's to get to 400 is doable that's the
key it's a month and everybody's like oh
that's so much to do or I hate these
like super heels you know the month
we're on day three same thing they said
on Twitter you know I'm like I mean if
you grind through it like some people
did in 24 hours which is insane mm-hmm
more power to you shout out to you I
didn't do it I'm only I just got the
blue Oh
I mean I got blue I've done a little bit
on my warlock but now I've been like
focused on the Titan mm and I worked for
a couple shifts so they didn't get as
much in and then finally gonna work on
some blue and purple this weekend but
now one thing and we'll get to a little
tweak here in a second so redux missions
are cool so you got homecoming which is
the first mission which is cool there's
more enemies everywhere which is kind of
nice there's some in some places they
even added a few Saiyans he had to do so
you didn't get picked off so little
tweaks and stuff I'm kind of liking the
additions these are the way I hope
basically all future missions like hard
should be this level like yes this is
what I want so if you've done you've
liked all right I went through the
campaign I did the normal you want to go
play it again on hard okay we're gonna
take the story stuff out which is you
know you don't hear the commentary over
and over which is half good and then
cranked everything up so that was cool
if spark is insane
popping up servitor popping up more
servitors by the way when it comes to
payback the tank mission lay it safe you
get one tank mm so when you do this
don't go rush and be like oh I'm gonna
get another pad or whatever you can heal
this thing a little bit on the pads yeah
but that's it it's you the whole thing
by yourself and there are so many
enemies in there oh it's insanely yeah
you're right tank so that might be one
to find a buddy yes these things shout
out the ready someone at a post it's
like the love of God take a fire chief
with you like I was watching our I saw
what Paul TAS sees he's like I'm so far
and I'm like I've died so many times but
it's like it's kind of the level of
challenge some of us like one more than
we like think we do but it's like at
least it's something to like I feel like
if I'm working through it it's like okay
this is like a legit challenge for
destiny which is good but yeah payback
for sure take it light take it slow
absolutely Almighty they shortened that
one up for sure which isn't bad but they
definitely shorten it um but I still oh
is one of the coolest looking when you
travel through that tunnel just that
moment where you're like I'm flying
through an energy tunnel apparently I'm
okay radioactive energy beam I'm fine
I'm fine but also you just look out and
see the Sun it's just like one of those
moments the first time you did it I'm
like yeah they still got some
awesomeness to him so Bungie still
crushing it and then chosen he's also
one you're probably gonna want a group
for for one there's little Scorpius
little mini guns everywhere in the
little platforming part when you get to
him between the ads and also his like
running around and stuff like that solos
gonna be rough I got a do it solo I
haven't done him yet I mean I ran
through all five with my brother to help
him out oh you ran with two people but
by yourself yeah you're gonna be um it's
gonna be rough yeah absolutely
so also what do you think of the moments
of triumph so far those have been close
local those are cool but I've always
liked stuff like that because it rewards
like like you know I know from day one
like I like so many just off the jump
you know and I was just like wow those
are proud proud moments because you know
you it represents the hard core and the
dedication to the game and you know if
make sure you finish this raid and that
raid I actually got to get prestige
either worlds and I still have not
touched spire of stars at all never done
it so I haven't either so you're not
alone okay yeah cuz I felt kind of bad
about a we're in this period right now
just so much to do and I get caught up
and I've been really you know doing a
lot of stuff catalyst crying crucible
Don I'm so close because I want I'm so
close to second prestige Dom on valor
I'm at legend and my first one yeah I
was like I'm trying to make sure I get
my mm-hmm I want to get my armor upgrade
to count before I reset and be in the
wrong place
I gotcha that's why I haven't money
because I'm sitting there a dick knows
like I want it to count so I heard like
if it is at legend like you're at the
highest level week you have to have it
at that level go in to at least accrue
some meta then it hopefully it'll take
off like so sometimes it's not counting
if you're there so just watch that one
but that's why I haven't gone for round
two yet so
but I mean overall they're cool they
give you their like ultra bounties fun
stuff to do and this is what I hope we
get so much more of an Forsaken yes
that's a cool ship and you got your
baseball which I didn't quite realize it
was your saw blade over here yes
literally when I did my weekly reset
with my warlock I was like oh I'll
record on here I was going through my
first character I got I got the witch
guys I got the chopper sparrow
Oh jealous y'all jelly are you still got
it on my firt all with my warlock if you
like the gift package BAM got it Wow dad
it looks cool I still want the Tron one
as well but I was like this is what it
looks it's totally unique doesn't look
like a sparrow BAM guys love video
creator love there I also got the
fishing one already to get out the bog
man I haven't got really a lot of cool
stuff yet just I got the shell two spiky
shell bet that one I got oh you didn't
get the subway I didn't get a saw blade
yep I got it I got that one man out one
squid he got some cool perks on I was
able to get rid of like two other ghosts
because it was exotic and I had like
three perks then I really wanted so yeah
very cool yeah so overall some pretty
solid stuff generally like and again it
works as a checklist so they learn their
lesson on round one check in those boxes
now so you won't be getting duplicates
of anything like crazy like that mm-hmm
developer insights if you haven't seen
it about this check it out it's cool
stuff yes trying to see if there's
anything else we got but yeah I think I
feel like we covered a lot faster no
just gonna be super lump when we rock I
mean any other stuff you want to talk
about right now feel of anything anybody
in check out any questions or anything
right now I got a little little moment
this is rarely like this was all talked
about in like an hour
ten minutes south the Crisco releases
that most of his trap triumphs done he's
been through legend many of times for
crucible few emotes on the ornaments for
source regime orangey is serving you
well he bothers no doubt good yeah
no it's like level 33 and level 37 for
my faction early armor sets I'll take a
little bit of orangey please yes please
so yeah that was like kind of my I guess
getting a little bit back but I mean I
look at the everything one going to talk
about I mean what quick oh I was gonna
say like how excited are you for a wrong
combat reveal street you know and looks
like they jumping right into to form
right with the whole Street look most
likely like I stream every week you
think towards release like what do you
think they're at with that was like you
think there's gonna be one every week
well I'm jet old format I mean excuse me
not every week you correct I am wrong
with that usually it would be like
almost like a bi-weekly thing though
right cuz usually up to a major DLC they
would do like the weapons and walk
around I'll show you this to show that
wait I feel like that was destiny one I
feel like they've kind of chunked it all
into one now for each expansion I know
this one's bigger
but I feel with everything we've seen
from Game Informer they've actually been
linking to those well I think this might
be if there's there might be one more at
a max like I know this will be I don't
know what else they would do though the
story we've seen a decent amount on
gambit already mean and then now we're
gonna cover TT cancel I don't know what
else they would do for another combat
reveal as much as I love that stuff
i low-key feel its leash you know I'm
saying like yeah like to me it's not
like you know I can't see them just
doing this in there okay see you
September either like I think it's gotta
be like at least one more you think I
mean like Game Informer did a full
mission playthrough we see gambit for
ever and ever
I mean there unless they show like mods
and stuff like I could see like
and perks and armors and weapons that
being a specific one but that could be
Tamar like next week as well so I was
like I don't no idea what you say I was
like I'm just trying to think of what it
would be I was like I wouldn't be
surprised marking wise if they want to
keep it going
for sure for the heightened stuff like
that like I could see one more but it
like for content for a full stream I'm
actually wracking my brain what it would
be yeah I heard you saying like it is
like almost everything we've been talked
about so far yeah boiler territory I
feel a lot yeah you're right I mean last
mini spoiler territory Oh heads up heads
up to the chat and for anybody no shout
out don't play of course on top of his
game apparently there's some type of um
collector said have you seen this with
cards yep and the Queen's in there okay
so you know what's up so that's it but I
mean we don't know what content you know
capacity what role it looked like the
old version of the Queen which was um
you know right the imagery right that
she looked like prior to Oryx wiping
them away okay so it's interesting that
you know it's like a low-key spoiler
almost like when the toys come out and
they're on a foreshadow like there was
the red war toys and red Legion and all
that then we knew we were fighting a
cabal you know same kind of thing you
usually toys or notorious for kind of
you know bringing that stuff as far as
to direction so it's very interesting
because I still think there's a lot of
mystery there with her that they're
holding back which I have no problem
with that and um you know just to see
obviously who the ultimate in game we
all have our theories but you know once
once the holes are things Sabbath ins a
big theory about Queen Queens how about
Queen savathun put them
Sabbath soon checked with the Queen
she's all pissed off cuz we didn't treat
her right now she's hell hath no fury
like a woman scorned um I mean I don't
know all day long but see I'm kind of
curious I'll look at legendary gear
that's another thing in the stream if
they're gonna talk about like upgrading
legendary gear in their ways they talked
about cuz you can get like 10 upgrade
levels on your like master or some crazy
stuff like that for your some of those
things are gonna be interesting so I
love how they still said no exotic
master work armor that was one of those
questions in the QA they said no master
work armor I'm like what I'm upset by
that how is that not a thing like yeah
even right now if you don't balance all
like the extra bonus like at least let
us master work it for the percentage
yeah otherwise you use a messed working
you give up the like what is it 10% now
cuz it was 25 no I mean the only thing
is it just seems like maybe they can't
come up with something I don't know man
you know almost always been that thing
being you that's what I do agree my
armors always been that thing with
destiny just very they over casual eyes
it and it's a shame because um you know
the only thing that they revealed was
that the d1 style perks would be kind of
returning so scout rifle you have ping
in this one you know how they have
different perks on it so it does make
sense certain sets will have you know
they do we got confirmation on the gear
bonuses outside of some stupid emblem or
something I mean that's all they've said
it's like if you get a gear set like you
get a full collection of like deborah
McKay's armor you might get an emblem
for that I'm like I'm so tired of
emblems come on I mean I don't even
think about changing that often like I
finally got the bill I finally got the
kill death ratio perk for crucible yeah
I got it last week
Wow so but I still don't care about him
that much like some are cool like the
first time you get to raid one for like
Seva
okay that was a cool light badge to say
okay I've completed it but after a while
most
we'll have them where they don't or
they're moving them around so it doesn't
really it doesn't clarify that much and
say like hey I'm cool or I did this that
or the other or even if you did it
doesn't do anything I'm like I want
armor to matter that's right like if I
was gonna go in the budget you want one
thing just like this five thousand watts
Interac you see me farmer needs to
matter and I know that's vague and not
specific but like I want perks I want
builds I want like set bonuses the way
the weapons feel is how the armor needs
to feel mm-hmm so I just absolutely
absolutely it neat they need to have
that that our fantasy they're you know
and they need to be able to do some
they're talking about investment all the
time you know you're talking about
investment with the weapons now and um
and what you call it in a forsaken
levelling up with you and that kind of
stuff you gotta you have to do the same
for armor you know again this is where
they kind of tote the line with you know
casual you know shared shooter
experience as opposed to you know a true
dedicated MMO that ultimately a lot of
people still want so you know I get it
know sometimes they still have that
little bit of those casual jeans in
their system but a man it would be cool
to see you know exotic armor you know
truly full-fledged or just at least give
us like we've been saying if he is right
legendary gear set bonuses for having
the entire Iron Man asset on and you
know what man means a lot it encourages
diversity of play styles you know so I
mean the Wraiths said the braid perks
are a tiny step in the right direction
but if you have the were a full range
set of armor give it a perk is like if
you wearing a full set you should get
something for that exactly you're giving
up an exotic slot like that's the other
key yeah like on that exotics but then I
guess they're if they're wonder if they
don't do set bonuses then who would use
anything like again bump the exotics but
yeah like gear set bonuses I mean that's
like what division is literally based
around is like their sets and their
bonuses if you have to you get this
little perk and it could be something
just a similar like hey if you weren't
two sets of the Devvarman case that you
might get you know your Grenada
recharges like a little bit faster or
something even
something tiny like that would make me
pick my builds differently as that's all
I'm going for just crazy pills yeah
preach it preach and that's shot the
carboxy because he's a big division guy
and he loves built-in Nats with the hawk
or division guys they like that you know
I'm saying like they it really gets down
in my new show with a plus dis to this
this that and that's that and depending
on your play style you know imagine if
destiny had that like how much deeper it
would be you know and he already took
away the you know the perks subclass
trees from us timing yeah it gave us a
microwave version pre-made TV dinner
class that you just like it's not the
Gordon Ramsay five star to the right
temperatures perfect cook level to get
that nice sear on the steak no I just
like I've well done the Ace or loin to
shoot whether it's like exactly so many
times you've wanted me to have fries
with a certain be like the variety come
on one man we had it we owe you had at
least that low you've messed around with
those nodes right and yes I did but it
got to the point they got bad because of
some builds were like so much better no
rest in peace the the Sun sing well like
grenades with the Viking funeral that's
like that's what maybe one play max that
was it like those pieces are like I mean
okay so I was part of literally like my
nightfall setup like okay so I'm riding
solo I want to turn on the perk that's
gonna make sure when I get a solar type
kill I get healing back but I'm running
with a group that's not as crucial
because I've got Reza's so I can go for
more explosions on my hammers and things
like it like it changes your play style
it really does mm-hm
so I mean if perks are gonna be smaller
I mean even just something where it's
like okay so I'm wearing two pieces of
gambit
I have more sword ammo like even just
random specific stuff where if you
eventually hunt around like maybe Sloan
on titan has like five pieces gets you
like you know an extra rocket perk or a
little just little things like that give
you a reason to go hunt stuff down and I
think that's if they want it to be a
hobby they need to get that in and
that's the last piece and I don't think
it has to be crazy like five point three
seven six percent like division level of
perks right I don't think it has to be
that I think you can be just living like
you know faster grenade recharge time or
more ammo it doesn't have to be quite as
detailed but some bonus when wearing
multiple pieces just gives you a reason
so I need to go grind on Titan for a
little while getting me a few more
tokens and go for that you know that
second piece of armor whatever so those
are little things we want I'm that's
I've said it for I don't even know how
many podcasts armor needs work you know
probably I'm gonna be like dust and
mine's gonna be now how many days since
the armor from destiny 2 does not suck
no no and ultimately it may be the three
thing which would suck but I'm hoping
between the next couple of expansions
with these weird names but number and
Wow Joker well these contents coming
hopefully you can say between this time
if they if they stick to the mission or
what they've been doing so far you know
each release they've been adding
something and changing stuff so one
could hope that maybe we evolved in
don't have to wait to add III so let's
see let's see but I'm height man I'm
really high this we getting closer each
week I feels like there's some new news
that gets me excited you know we got a
stream literally coming out how you want
to handle man what you wouldn't do what
what do you guys can
as far as for the stream if we want to
recap it or save it Friday we can
probably save it for Friday I mean no
but oh we good are we holding out to
Friday because that's a big one that's a
big one we can bring that offline but we
got to decide how we're gonna
this is the same between he and I and
then we'll kind of announce be like a
fresh reactions I mean I won't be able
to watch YouTube for three days if we do
that yeah everyone else is going to talk
about it yeah it was like honestly like
stuff like time to kill him weapon slots
is not like the reveal of forsaken
though cuz like that nine-minute vyak so
much to cover I have a feeling this
might actually be a little more tame
like we'll get some info but we've got
so much already I feel like yeah there'd
be some cool moments but honestly if you
waited I feel like you'd probably be
alright yeah I don't know we'll talk and
figure that out but one way to there
next week will be 12 and reveal stream
coverage mostly talking about what's in
there well yeah I'm looking forward to
everything my brother was nice enough
for my birthday to buy me Monster Hunter
on PC because you'd only problem with
that is it comes out like Tuesday yeah
right listen I've become up because of
solstice because of all these days you
know rallies and do it I'm back full
time you know all the suffering man and
it just I know how idea this is when
destiny becomes a full-time job which is
low-key what the hard core what we love
so yeah yeah but it's also it's like I
neglect so many games like I didn't play
a couple years ago many things got
neglected because of destiny so damn you
destiny my life yeah but honestly like
great stuff coming so few weeks away
guys it's August forsaken is literally
thirty two days away yeah work I'm ready
oh damn yeah you're ahead of me time
because that a couple trips so I'm gonna
be off and out I might see I know I'll
probably work Tuesday morning if my
schedule stays but that wins yeah I have
to see what I can do so but other than
that guys I think we can wrap it up here
hanging out everybody in Chet it was
awesome to talk with all you guys some
before the chat started some during and
always hit me up on Twitter TV or
twitch.tv about to see if you guys are
right there follow me you guys will know
when
stream I'll probably stream a decent
mint this weekend since I know I've got
a lot of time
twitter.com always our crazy antics or
just updates of all YouTube it made up
on there guys if you have not subscribed
hit up both of us both iron Lords
podcast and II bought this channel my
artist for my logo redesigned you guys
heard about I was out of town so that
got like pushed off and then it came
back in his whole world got like he lost
like all his info like hard drive crash
so he's got a rebuild mine which you
still got the images so probably won't
take too long but overall that'll be
coming and yeah just follow us
everywhere we're gonna keep the stuff
coming for you so I'm trying to figure
out what videos I'll - I'll do this
weekend for what do you I mean what
would be most useful for you like
someone like throw on a mission tips on
like super kills in crucible
yeah just tips I mean I think
everybody's in the grind so just like
you know tips on you know effective
strategies like I said I loved you know
please watch bonuses whispered the worm
like I said if you still haven't got a
chance to do it you know as a terrible
jumper it was much appreciated
let's dig it cuz you glitch dinner right
yeah glitch damn how hard was that to do
through the video I'm not that difficult
my second or third attempt if I remember
it like it wasn't that hard I just learn
and follow your instructions step by
step and then you know it's specific
specifically I'm such a terrible warlock
jumper because of the flu thing that oh
you know I got to tell you exactly
though so I I got frustrated because my
teen my clan mates were already in the
room there was so much like they they
could almost have you know to man did
what just be getting to the room would
have helped you know I mean and I got so
frustrated I I didn't because of your
video video actually gave me a little
more confidence I wasn't that far I was
I literally just kept going into the
wrong orb to that could've got me into
that room you know with a room with the
Globes so um yeah yeah that's where I
kept going too far I went off into where
a secret chest was didn't know you know
then I just kept going in well it was it
was a disaster so they ended up not
doing it on my first attempt but was
able to get back in there and then kind
of like I said watch it thing and then
went through and I'm like boom not this
time last one on the top right I know
would it go it is it and then got into
that room and we started deep yes in and
going crazy so yeah like I said anybody
hasn't done this I think for UCS summer
social stuff you know kind of easier
farms and stuff like that with the kana
you know by the way if you're a Titan
the solar kills for the blue set so
solar and super kills for your blue the
350 level headpiece mm-hmm is ultra slow
on Titans it's kind of raining oh wow Oh
heads up that's gonna be a grind glasses
not so much
yeah solar super kills because I
finished like solar something else and I
was like done I was like and I'm at 13%
on the head pieces like what the hell so
it's gonna be like go to a public event
flag throw that stuff go to another but
like it's gonna be like I mean that's
the general grind to say it anyway
I mean I said that probably in the other
video that I did for upgrading virtual
examples so that's probably the way to
do it so absolute yeah shout out you got
iron Lords podcast coming up on Sunday
absolutely takes a crisco both shouting
out for flashpoint yes you need to
subscribe there bonta's please get on
that yes Lord's return to the realm of
the Lords on Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern on
the inner circle Network YouTube channel
and we will have Lord boomstick veteran
gamer very knowledgeable and diverse saw
lineup of games that he covers and plays
as well as the two three podcasting ones
he's kidding
pretty not that new in the community but
he's been he's been rocking a while and
he's just been growing and loved the
vibe so my boomstick will be in the
building Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern
obviously on the ILP channel you still
have flashpoint and you still have ILP
and of course combat talk with the king
talkin everything in boxing mixed
martial arts all that good stuff so
please check us out and again make sure
you sub to my brethren Avant is man
great contact the man helped the poor
warlock person Lupin I'm saying like he
has sympathy for my class I respect
that's yeah me too so twitch Twitter
YouTube follow us find us hit us up if
you're on PC
i'm ebonne test number 1305 nice that's
me on pc i'm about to sever wills but
that's where i'm playing destiny right
now because Brady and I can't get away
from it like the looks it could look D
at frame yeah it's the feel of the game
I said look I'm trying but I said I
understand what he's going through
it's after you spin to the mountaintop
there's no paint
looking a pretty see and everything you
come down looking through the fog all I
can pray for his next generation
cross-play whenever you build your
computer you get everything so when it
happens you have to join me on PC by the
way if you buy the collection yes you
dollar Forsaken and all of your one
bundle gonna be able to get that boost
for your character yeah I need that
boost not that really yeah yeah see you
trap of it you're real quick on Xbox I
forgot to guys that I'm going on and one
Xbox as Lord cockney know so Lord with
the space and then um yeah man PC
hopefully soon you know they're not
Twitter is more kognito as well so
that's what I got that's about it I
guess it feels like faster than I
probably would our namesake
yeah closer to it so I know we kind of
rambled on here but yeah you guys got
the most of it but yeah next week we'll
talk about the
ttk reveal see if they cover weapons
armor and stuff moving around who knows
what all that has to hold and then
outside of that enjoy the grinds on
Soulstice guys it's it's fun at least if
nothing else if the grounds like don't
really do it for you go try the missions
even if it's with a couple of buddies
just to experience the Redux ones what's
Custer cool
and you probably won't be able to see
him that way again so have some fun with
that enjoy pre-order the game
don't pre-order the game wait for us to
tell you it's cool after it comes out
because flashpoint on September 7th is
probably going to be redonkulous oh my
god I can't wait we getting close yep so
that is about it guys to everybody thank
you as always for the support the chat
and the love every week's great cuz you
guys so thank you thank you hmm
absolutely good one
have a good on season babies